Canadian
parents love their kids and we want the
very best for them and we want them to
be kept safe LGBT youth across this
country are among the most vulnerable to
homelessness to
Suicide to a range of things that can
harm
them we need to be there to defend them
we need to be there to protect them and
I know Canadians across the country are
doing just
that it is
telling that the week after welcoming uh
farri American conservative Tucker
Carlson to her Province to sit with him
on stage Danielle Smith has now moved
forward with the most
anti-lgbt policies of anywhere in the
country Canadians need to know that the
federal government H and uh all
Canadians uh will be there to protect
youth as a federal government we will
always be there to protect uh the most
vulnerable uh particularly vulnerable
LGBT youth who need to know uh that
there are people across the country
there to fight for them uh I you if if
Premier Smith wants to fight someone uh
stand with us and fight for Canadians on
Lower grocery prices
on uh affordable fuel on more housing on
fighting climate change fight with us to
defend the rights of vulnerable
Canadians don't fight against vulnerable
LGBT
youth